let me jump in and say how much i effing
love this movie oh thanks it is like
easily one of my favorites of the year
you guys both did such a tremendous job
along with James Mangold who directed
the [ __ ] out of this yeah it's such a
great job with it look at your leather
brace would you call them
these bands actually elephant hair and
giraffe hair you really didn't believe
it
I swear bad and the other one this is
leather alright but you remember that
band aha
yep cool take on take on me look at the
to you big fans on here right it didn't
that bloke used to wear those I don't
remember but we've really got enough on
the on the tangents here and I want to
pull yeah but no but they did a video
wasn't the take on me video about race
car driver was it wasn't it like a guy
trying to yes it was right there you go
so actually I was right wrapped around
did not see that coming mmm I give you
props mmm okay um so one of them listen
you guys are both two of my favorite
actors and you deliver such like amazing
performances and everything I see I'm
just curious
do you guys ever sincerely get nervous
before doing the scene or you reached a
place in your career where you sort of
like you feel like you have it if you
know what I mean I don't get nervous
before a scene necessarily unless I'm
just my head somewhere else that day and
I know I'm not in the right headspace
and I'm going or I come on me come on me
get there before a film the entirety of
the film I always go what how come they
think and I can do this and where do I
begin
and I don't know that if that comes from
not being trained and so I kind of
everytime feel like I'm winging it again
let's see how this goes but I always get
that feeling ahead of time of like oh
dear this is nobody realizes that I've
done how to do this I was nervous on the
first day of this one because I hadn't
worked for two years and and I just like
I just remember going to set the first
day and it didn't it felt foreign where
as for so many years it feels like kind
of what life is supposed to feel like
and a knife and I remember I kind of
went
doing you know and it's that it's the
same version of what Christians talking
about but it's usually before the movie
I mean I remember saying that to
Soderbergh before we did behind the
candelabra I was with him the day before
and I I just said I have no idea what
I'm gonna do tomorrow
you know you mean and it's like you've
thought about it you've done it's like
but I guess now we're just gonna do it
and something's gonna actually what
happened here but I don't think it's bad
to feel nervous I think it just shows
that you're still yes sired by you still
feel something by it you know yeah I'd
be a little bit troubled if sorry you
want this no no I'm you only sound sort
of stopped but I just want to bring it
back to Morten Harket I am curious
though with making this this is such a
tremendous film do you know on day one
that like man we're making something
special here do you know it when you
have the script or is it only when it
finally you see the finished film are
you like oh wow that's really came
together in my experience that's when
you see the finished film like that like
all you can hope for by the time of your
UN shooting is to feel like well I feel
like we got everything we were we set
out to get you know I we I love that
script I feel like every day went pretty
well and and there's not a day I wish I
could have back now let's hope at all
coheres and it comes together and some
and sometimes it does and sometimes it
doesn't it's amazing so there's a really
fun scene for me of you two fighting
when you are going to get the groceries
and you guys have been in such big
movies with these big choreographed
fights what is it like doing something
where it's just the two of you really
just fighting on the grass like how much
fun was that see way more realistic yeah
way more realistic about what a fight
between Christian Bale and Matt Damon
would really look like yes yeah they
said just have a fight and we'll tape it
basically what happened but ya know it
was fun to do a silly fight like that
and we were you know we always have to
take those things really seriously and
look really like
what we're doing so it was fun to have a
fight between two pathetic middle-aged
guys who don't really know how to fight
on that note I need to go um I seriously
congrats on smoothies I'm so effing good